[Music]
Abby Lee Miller is a free woman
The Dance Moms star has been released
from the Federal Correctional Complex in
Victorville California Miller was
originally sentenced to one year and one
day in federal prison last July after
pleading guilty to bankruptcy fraud in
June 2016 now a source tells ET that the
51 year old reality star is looking
forward to her new life outside of
prison adding that she will have quote
lots and lots to say a second source
reveals that Abby will go under the
knife again very soon last April prior
to her sentencing the dance instructor
underwent gastric bypass surgery a
procedure that reduced her stomach by
80% I think this is the right time you
know people are saying but your
sentencing is coming up in a couple
weeks and this that the other thing and
that is true and I'm really nervous
about that more than the surgery but
there's no right time in July 2017 Abby
told ET that the time behind bars would
be an opportunity for her to concentrate
on herself I've always put everybody
else's child first before my own health
before my own outfit before my own time
frame you know everybody else was
dressed and out the door and looking
perfect and I was running around trying
to find a clean towel to take a shower
with so I think this will be a little me
time
[Music]